the next award is for the best
achievement in cinematography an award
to the cameraman
they sell to make the fan magazines but
without them hollywood we would be
stripped of much of its glamour and here
to present the award mr robert ryan
for the best achievement in
cinematography of a black and white
production
those nominated are a foreign affair
paramount charles b lange jr
i remember mama rko radio nicholas
moussaraka
johnny belinda warner brothers ted
mccord
the naked city mark hellinger
productions universal international
william daniels
portrait of jenny the selznick studio
joseph august
william daniels for the naked city mark
hellinger
but the best achievement in
cinematography of a color production
those nominated are the green grass of
wyoming 20th century fox charles g clark
joan of arc sierra pictures rko radio
joseph valentine william v skull and
winton hawk
the loves of carmen the beckwith
corporation colombia william snyder the
three musketeers metro golden mayor
robert plank
or joan of arc
joseph valentine william b scall and
winton hawk
thank you very much bob ryan